how much value these days is a college
degree well ever since the pandemic
there's been a bit of a shift from
expensive degrees to skill sets
upskilling much more widespread we
talked to a tech expert on what it is
how you can go about it to secure your
new job or a promotion in the tech
fields
despite recent layoffs the demand for
Tech talent in certain areas like coding
cyber security and data analytics
continues to build technology is moving
very very fast ananta argarwal is an MIT
professor and the founder and CEO of
edex one of the largest online educators
of technical talent in the world its
popularity has soared to some 46 million
users as more people are looking to
upskill you learn you get a degree
whether it's in engineering or in
Psychology you find that as technology
moves you have to keep
adding a shot of something or the other
over time so that you can keep current
with technology keep current with your
job and that's upskilling whether it's
someone choosing to secure hybrid skills
to gain that promotion at a current Tech
job or someone looking to secure their
very first job Argo will says more young
people are choosing this path the whole
gen z a generation uh you know has a
much lower trust in higher education in
college than the baby boomer generation
and whether it's securing a professional
certificate say in data science from
Harvard or cloud computing from IBM
there are more than 50 Partners at top
institutions and big companies today we
have courses from MIT Harvard Berkeley
top companies like Google and IBM and
meta Amazon web services and others
edx was created in 2012 to expand access
to high quality education to everyone
its very first class circuits
Electronics had 155 000 Learners from
more than 160 different countries as
opposed to just a hundred students who
would have been taught in classrooms at
MIT